kaley macanani she's the white house
press secretary it looks like she's on
the north lawn kayla good morning to you
great to join you good to have you okay
so griff was just talking about
the situation down in georgia where
they've got the twin runoff races first
week in january
and he brought up uh you know the
president is talking about how the
election was rigged
and there are a number of republicans
who are worried that that kind of
thing could backfire on that particular
runoff election because
they say you know if it's rigged if the
if the 2020 november election was rigged
and this one's rigged why should i even
bother voting
yeah you know i'll leave it to the
campaign to pontificate on the
president's strategy with
sometimes you're with the campaign so
you know the thinking there
i do i'm joining you in my official
capacity today from the white house lawn
but i'll say this the president has been
unapologetic for the last 10 months
in saying that mail-in voting mass mail
and voting is subject to fraud
this has been a key part of what he's
talked about when it comes to election
integrity he wants to make sure
signatures are matched uh the mail-in
voting is sacrosanct and is treated with
the integrity that every american vote
deserves that it's actually
encapsulating the vote of the american
people but can't that come back
to backfire with this georgia special
election
no because the president again look if
you go back to when nancy pelosi took
the gavel
the very first bill she put in place was
hr1 this was
to allowing people on voting roles
illegal immigrants on voting rolls no
signature matching
democrats for years far before the 2016
election
uh the 2020 election rather have tried
to make our election system less secure
the president is going to continue to
fight for that
while also saying it's important to turn
out and vote while also perfect
perfecting the system so kaylee we want
you to respond to this the ap
they put out an article about the the
female staff communication staff that
biden has selected
they wrote four of the seven top
communication roles at the white house
will be filled by women of color
and it's the first time the entire
senior white house communications team
will be entirely female i know that you
blasted the paper some of your staffers
did
saying hey look at us we're all female
then you had a guy who's one of the
staffers who works on your team i know
all the bosses are females
and he said since i arrived at the trump
white house a woman has always been my
boss first it was hope picks
mercedes schlapp and sarah sanders then
it was stephanie grisham and of course
currently it's kaylee mcinney and elisa
farah
i guess the media forgot his name is
judd dear what's your reaction because
they're saying that you're lying about
it
yeah judd dear is a great member of our
team every
senior role in the white house senior
role in the white house
is a female this president out of the
five press secretaries that have been
women
uh three of them have been under
president trump he appointed the first
working mom and sarah sanders
then appointed another working mom and
then appointed me uh with a newborn
under the age of one he's consistently
empowered women but the double standard
in the media is absolutely absurd
if you're a democrat woman who comes
into the west wing behind me who takes
that podium
your biggest concern outside of your
official duties is the next glowing
profile written about you
if you're a female woman in the
republican party who takes that podium
guess what your worry is having a
playboy reporter shout
questions at you demeaning misogynistic
questions during a briefing
it's a double standard it's one that's
ridiculous and one of the white house
correspondents association
should look into when you have playboy
reporters shouting at women
in a misogynistic manner simply because
they're a member of the gop
i think judd dear needs a promotion it
doesn't by how many bosses he's had
uh he does a really good job if we can
go to operation warp speed
we are waiting the planes are ready to
go the vaccine is ready to go the fda
isn't yet and according to the axios
mark meadows has some of the fda
commissioner stephen hahn
not to a zoom call but to show up in
person and explain
what the delay is there's a sense
they're not working around the clock and
that he went to the outer banks
to quarantine or vacation when you
really should be pushing the moderna
vaccine before
the middle of december and this pfizer
vaccine as in yesterday
what could you tell i know it's easy to
punt on this what could you tell us is
there a little bit of tension
that maybe the fda is not working as
hard as a cdc
and others like yourself and the
president well you know i don't want to
talk about the the meetings that will be
going on today in the in the west wing
but also what i'll say is this is
we're working around the clock uh you
had monsef salawi come out and say
normally a vaccine
takes between four years and 25 years
think about that a quarter of a century
in some cases
for a vaccine no but is the fda kaylie
is there essentially cut that the fda
isn't look i think the fda is working
around the clock as well this is a
partnership here
uh everyone wants to see american life
saves from dr stephen hahn
to this president but this president
will never apologize
for putting the fire under these
agencies to say yes we want a safe
vaccine
absolutely we also want to fast one
because lives are at stake
and a vaccine by the end of the year is
key and paramount and that's exactly
what this president has
done and he'll continue to push agencies
to be rapid but to be safe
right and uh in the early days the
administration
said to the governors you know what
because different localities are you
know have different conditions
everybody should be in charge of things
in their own states
some of the governors are talking about
more lockdowns or restrictions i know in
rhode island yesterday they sent out a
text alert to everybody
hey for the next couple of weeks uh try
to stay as close to home as you possibly
can how does the administration feel
about these new restrictions
in various places all across the country
because it looks as if right now
you know there's something like 41
states that it's spiking in
yeah and we're at a different place
today look we locked down the country
once and it's because it was a novel
virus that came in that we did not have
therapeutics for
uh that we did not know how to handle
because we didn't have testing it was
novel no one had ever seen coven 19.
we know how to handle it now americans
we're responsible we know how to wash
our hands and socially distance and wear
a mask and make wise decisions
but governors should trust their people
to make the right decisions this
president's about freedom he's not about
shutting down businesses he's not about
locking down states and he's certainly
not about locking down places of
religious worship which the supreme
court said
uh it was unconstitutional what governor
cuomo was doing there in new york
because yes
we have a pandemic but we also have a
united states constitution and those
freedoms matter even amid a pandemic
kaylee i'm reading an article new york
times reporting on joe manchin and they
were interviewing him
in his office and he was working on the
coronavirus stimulus package he thinks
1.2 trillion is acceptable which is half
of what his party was pushing but he is
more of a moderate and wants to work
with republicans
brian interviewed a lady who owns a
restaurant earlier on our show
she said that she needs to lay off some
employees but she can't do it this close
to christmas
and she said a pregnant woman was in her
office crying saying please don't lay me
off and she's refusing to do that
but they're not making any money because
she owns a restaurant people need help
what's the latest
yeah what's the latest is joe manchin
needs to go have a discussion
with nancy pelosi who has been
fundamentally unserious in a way that's
irresponsible and quite frankly
disgusting that she resumes the house
puts the house back in session
and what are the bills she puts forward
about legalizing
marijuana about going after tiger king
and and regulating uh the
the um use of tigers instead of focusing
on
the american people and the relief
that's needed her stimulus bill
was chock full of guess what mail-in
voting regulations to try to secure
democrat power in the halls of congress
while this president said nancy pelosi
you won't negotiate with me well guess
what
i'll do protections from evictions i'll
do more funding
uh for for unemployment insurance via
executive order he's been serious while
nancy pelosi
has been derelicting in her duty and she
does not deserve to be speaker ever
again well
she almost lost it this time they within
striking distance so i got to tell you
mitch mcconnell is he's putting the heat
up on
nancy pelosi says there's no reason for
them not to have a relief
package and joe manchin senator warner
and dick durbin are working
uh with murkowski romney cassidy
and collins to try to get something done
they're trying to get
from bottom up leadership to actually
act
will the president pick up the phone and
get them to act
will he put the pressure on like he
always does behind the podium
he's continually put the pressure on and
i can tell you um having had daily
discussions with chief of staff mark
meadows the secretary of the treasury
steve mnuchin they've consistently moved
towards nancy pelosi on behalf of the
president as his surrogate going to the
hill
um and nancy pelosi has been laughable
so you she says she wants this amount of
funding to open
schools and we give that we give more
than that
and she rejects it she's been on serious
so we'll continue to move towards
the left but that bipartisan group again
needs to put pressure on the radical
aocs of the world and ilhan omars that
control nancy pelosi like a marionette
puppet
i thought it was kind of the president
to reach out to joe biden on twitter and
say look i
wish you the best i hope you get well
soon but then some of the media were
criticizing him questioning whether or
not he was sincere
what was your reaction or what was the
president's reaction no the president
was absolutely being sincere um you know
we're one country we all have our
parties but at the end of the day we're
all americans that's what this president
recognizes
that's what this president understands
but leave it to the media to continually
take him out of context i think the
worst of him it's just what they do and
we're used to that here in the trump
administration
all right kaley thank you very much for
joining us from the north lawn on this
first day of december
thanks steve all right